what
we're at Bondi Beach in Sydney one of
the really famous beaches in the world
and I'm here thinking about chemistry
the obvious thing to think about is
sunscreen because Australians are always
using it and it's famous in Australia
that you need sunscreen to protect
yourself from the Sun so I've just
bought some sunscreen here's the tube it
says sport not entirely my scene and it
has this number here 30 Plus which shows
the actor how strong it is 30 plus
sunscreen is better than 20 plus not as
good as 40 plus so what the sunscreen
really need to do so it is trying to
protect you from the ultraviolet light
coming from the Sun because it is the
ultraviolet light that irritates the
skin causes burning so somehow you want
to filter out the ultraviolet light and
there are really two different ways that
you can do this you can either use some
sort of particles that will scatter the
light in the way that sugar makes a
light scattered and sugar looks white a
crystal of sugar is colorless but if you
take a bowl of sugar it looks white so
I'm squeezing some on here you can see
it's white and as I spread it out
it's making quite a nice white color all
over my skin I think the way that this
particular sunscreen is working you see
it's all white and I think even if I rub
it'll still make my skin white is that
it's not absorbing the ultraviolet light
but it's scattering it the sunscreen
contains very small particles of
material doesn't really matter what and
because they're a similar size to the
wavelength of light it causes the light
to scatter instead of going straight
through its scattered in all directions
and in fact behaves a bit like a mirror
so what's happening is it reflects the
light off of the surface the sunscreen
works well but you can imagine that not
everybody wants their skin to look quite
so white so an alternative approach is
to put in your sunscreen some sort of
organic chemical which is harmless to
the person will not hurt them if you put
it on their skin but because of its
molecular structure will absorb the
ultraviolet light so all being well in
let's visible light through so your skin
still looks pink but it absorbs the
ultraviolent so you don't get burnt and
the really cunning sort of sunscreen has
a mixture of the two uses small crystals
of something that absorbs ultraviolet
light then you get the best of both
worlds it scatters some of the light and
at the same time it absorbs the rest so
you get a really high protection factor
a very common particle to be used is
zinc oxide and this particular one says
it's using zinc so I think that probably
is zinc oxide the other compound that is
used a lot is titanium dioxide the same
material we use in white paint and if
you make titanium dioxide particles very
small they appear transparent but they
will still absorb ultraviolet light then
of course in your creme
you have to put various other additives
so that when you go swimming for example
it doesn't all wash off if you put chalk
all over your skin it would make it nice
and white but as soon as you went in the
water the water go white and you would
not be protected and so this particular
material says that it will be water
resistant for four hours now here were
the waters nice and warm and the
weather's hot four hours is possible in
England you wouldn't need sunscreen that
exists four hours in water you'd be far
too cold or for a few minutes
ultraviolet light causes photochemical
changes these are chemical reactions
that are produced by light and they can
cause changes in the skin which in the
end people believe can promote skin
cancer and so this is why this
particular brand is sponsored by the
Australian Cancer Council but in the
shorter term the ultraviolet light can
cause reddening of the skin and quite
serious burning many of you will
probably have had sunburn it's very
unpleasant
light has energy and if the molecules
absorb the energy that is often enough
to break bonds and when you break bonds
chemical reactions occur and there many
chemical reactions that are promoted by
light by far the most famous and the
most important to us is photosynthesis
where plants absorb light through their
green pigment that's why the leaves are
green and they then capture carbon
dioxide and generate oxygen and many
photochemical reactions are going on
around us we don't always notice them
because there's quite slow sometimes if
you have cloth around your window
curtains they sometimes fade because the
light of the Sun causes a photochemical
reaction in the dyes and your skin is
really quite sensitive and the day on
the beach unprotected is enough to cause
photochemical reactions that can cause
you quite a bit of discomfort